everything we're about to say we're only
pretending to know a lot about and are
still figuring most of it out so take it
with a word of caution or not salt salt
this advice liberally they're gonna make
a video telling you guys how we tell
stories now this is something that
people can go on forever and ever on you
guys would disagree with us but that's
cool we're just telling you what we
learned for me the first thing I keep in
mind is what is my goal telling a story
for us it's getting people to watch we
make youtube videos ask yourself the
next question is why is somebody going
to watch it why is somebody going to
watch gravity gun well they are a fan of
half-life 2 and they are familiar with
the gravity gun and there are not that
many quality half-life fan films out
there once the video starts you have to
start addressing those so why not start
it off with a really cool shot of a
gunship sweeping overhead right there
you've already set up boom this is as
big as it sounds second of all it's
hitting the kind of quality that I'd
expect from some sort of cinematic like
movie version of half-life 2 and we go
on to create a little plot that people
haven't seen before which is the origin
of the gravity gun and we make sure we
focus on delivering the story of the
gravity gun and figuring out what is
going to drive your video you
essentially are going to be able to be
building it with three pieces here
you're going to have the context which
is essentially your introduction setting
everything up you have pretty much the
core of the idea which is pretty much
why why you wanted to make the idea in
the first place whether it's an action
scene or some crazy effect and then
really at the end of it you have your
punch line and these kind of separate
sections are really what we've found is
like the formula that we're using for
our videos there's a big difference
between an idea for a video and the
context for a video for example the
sign-spinning video we just released the
actual idea for the video is sign
spinners who are really good at spinning
signs have a fight with their signs as
weapons the actual context for the piece
is what sets up that story about these
sign spinners fighting each other a
charming young sign spinner who has a
store robbed and must defend himself
with that sign another example is the
glitch the actual idea is doing glitchy
video game character effects such as
deformations of the face and clipping
through objects and lag the actual
context for the video ended up being two
video game characters come across a
glitch and don't know how to fix it
that's the biggest challenge you guys
will find in
writing a story is you'll get a cool
idea and then you got to figure out how
to turn that into an actual story and
that's where we spend a lot like most of
our time writing so we've talked about
how to like start your piece talk about
how to conceptualize it how to start
shooting it but at a certain point you
need to write the rest of the story and
ideally you write a compelling story
that keeps people interested how do you
do this comes down to two things
conflict and intrigue with conflict and
intrigue that's how you keep the story
rolling so what does this mean well for
example a person needs something but
there is a problem preventing them from
getting it there is no obvious solution
to this problem but they are going to
try how are they going to do it now
that's very vague we start applying it
to things and when you start applying
that to your story that's when you get
the actual interesting plot points and
character points and all that kind of
stuff glitch is also another good
example well it doesn't seem like
there's actually much conflict in the
opening piece there is it's these
characters arguing what what to do about
this glitch nobody has any idea what's
going to happen if if either decision is
made the intrigue builds once the glitch
starts happening because when it when it
starts growing and the guy glitches out
and the wall goes basically that is
mysterious people don't know what's
going to be happening now that this
glitch is spreading in a good story you
have to build from the get-go film is a
visual medium when it starts it needs to
be beautiful and pretty make that very
first picture somebody sees interesting
make it beautiful make it captivating
because there's no story yet you are
literally only one second into the video
there's zero story yeah and that can be
done with the actual quality the
composition the color correction set
design whatever or you can also just
tell it by what's happening on screen so
you're going to start with visual beauty
and then you're going to start
introducing very small story elements
let's go with brush with death we have a
beautiful image we have a guy who is
about to paint over that beautiful image
and it's just a little bite-sized story
but we're going to keep building then we
have the paint demon come to life and
fight off this guy who's about to erase
the image and that's the real story but
that doesn't kick in till like 2025
seconds into the piece and so in those
first 20 to 25 seconds it was key
they'll be percent of people with a
beautiful image some small bite-size
story chunks and intrigue leading into
the bigger piece the picture is worth a
thousand words
tell a story with your visuals
use your camera dummy what do visual
traits imply on a character does the
character have an eyepatch do they have
a beard do they have a scar are they
clean-cut do they wear a tie do they
wear a suit these all mean things fill
out all these details on all the
characters on the world in this
environment where is the camera looking
what's it showing what are the colors
and the scenes I'm right it's a dark
because it warrants a cold I got into a
bad fight yesterday and you could
believe me or I could just show up
wearing freaking a big black eye and a
bloody nose and I don't have to say a
thing people know that it's something I
got beat up doing something also camera
movement is just as important for
example the camera moves it reveals
things reveal this well the camera can
focus on things or it can just simply
like punch in on something or like frame
something up so it's focused in the
center so camera movement and camera
focus along with what's actually in the
scene is what lets you compose a visual
story so there's one shot in tether
we're looking at a house and it's
covered with frost and the camera is
moving by and we see as an old run-down
car and some random pieces of metal and
there's a yellow pickup truck in the
distance and there's a guy dragging a
dead body and another guy is stepping
outside the door and he looks
flabbergasted like what happened that
image right there that single image
tells a thousand things we have the
environment it's run down it's kind of
brown it's cold we have the house the
house is still in working order but it's
also kind of run down we have garbage in
the front yard we have an old broken car
and other bits of technology that are no
longer in use but we still have a
working pickup truck sitting there
parked in the yard mind you so clearly
the grass is not an issue with keeping
the grass nice we have a dead body so
somebody probably just got murdered
we've got dragging the body so we have a
guy who is probably the guy who murdered
that guy it was a guy coming out the
house looking shocked so he probably
didn't anything to do with it and
doesn't want to have anything to do with
it right they're literally just that one
picture sets up a ton of stuff and when
you can do that with your shots you make
things incredibly interesting and you
make your story so densely packed that
people are compelled to watch you want
to make sure you are focusing on what
you are trying to tell with your story
it's easy to get lost in tangents and
quicks and character details funny
moments your actor can make a funny face
and get them making a lot of funny faces
no focus on what you need
tell your story and get to your point
you actually find out what your story is
about by figuring out your ending
because the ending is what everything
amounts to in the piece you have the
character begins with the problem they
resolve it they learn something you have
an arc but there's other types of
stories there's also the story of
escalation things constantly getting
worse or better or bigger or what have
you for a two minute video escalation
can be great you just need to bring
people to a territory they didn't expect
the be in by the end of the piece case
in point the sign-spinning video that
video doesn't actually resolve itself
it's not like Clint best sign-spinner in
the world has its store robbed and then
he beats up the robbers and takes the
money back the end no that's not the
story the story is Clint the
sign-spinner has this store robbed goes
to fight the thieves but then one of the
other thieves randomly is also a great
sign spinner and they fight and then
randomly it turns out that Clint's boss
the owner of the pizza shop is also way
better than both of them at spinning
signs and then it ends so there's not
actually resolution to that but if you
think about the escalation there you're
taking an idea and you're evolving it to
levels that aren't really quite expected
and you kind of just get your punchline
by whatever evolution you decide to end
on the focus on the piece is the joke
sign spinners doing martial arts and
signs and that ending of the boss coming
out at the big sign and twirling it
around and having the spectacle
perfectly locks into that focus and
wraps up the whole piece in regards to
what the whole point of that story was
to wrap things all up I want to talk
about Dungeons and Dragons for a moment
don't see a dragon's physics and Dragons
is excellent story telling practice
especially when you're the dungeon or
Game Master we really haven't talked
about plot realistically because plot is
a byproduct of everything else plot is
not how you start writing a story plot
is what happens after you've written the
story the best Dungeons & Dragons game
happened when we had all created
interesting characters with their own
opinions beliefs motivations backstories
they weren't necessary the same between
each one they could conflict you need to
put them in a situation
that challenges them and puts them
either at odds with each other or at
odds of the situation more ideally both
and then you step back and you see what
happens exactly the characters drive the
plot the plot does not drive the
characters and that's what we learn from
playing Dungeons and Dragons create
characters the beliefs and opinions and
skills and all this kind of stuff the
situation is then informed by what the
character wants and desires and that's
when the plot happens because the
character then takes action it's very
easy to get caught up with you I want
the scene to happen I want things to go
down like this very often you'll find
yourself struggling to create those
scenes because it doesn't make sense for
why it should happen and what you need
to do is go back to these characters
these people who are in it look at
everything else that's led up to this
point for them and ask yourself is this
what they should be doing or what would
they realistically be doing here if a
character makes a decision that does not
make sense the people watching the video
something realize that that character is
a construct and not a real person and
the illusion is lost nope no yep no
longer stories as much actors we're
always trying to figure this stuff out
for ourselves here this is just kind of
what we've learned to this point there's
many exceptions to all these rules and
you kind of just have to see for
yourself where things go we try to read
pretty much all the comments especially
for like the first couple days and the
videos out leave us detailed feedback we
love reading it are you going to hit us
up on Twitter with your thoughts or
Facebook what you don't quite read as
frequently but we post a lot of updates
there anyways guys thanks for watching
see you later